so leute männerherzen bereit hallo
ich will meinen körper stählen ich will
den härtesten prüfungen unterziehen und
und damit ich kampf bereit bin habt ihr
da war es für mich kriegen hinab ein
kleines programm für mich um mich zu
natürlich dinge am richtigen
und 1 unterliegen das jahres haben wir
haben bei mir sie haben wir haben zu mir
schon etwas jetzt einfach und jetzt
unter druck und so scheint hoch zur
aufgabe
[Gelächter]
das wird nur ein liegen stets genau
wissen erwärmt
sich auch die gäste ohne hochkommen
immer
[Gelächter]
richtig
ich habe wir haben bei dir und wenn du
nicht bekannt sagst du wechsel und lässt
mich schlagen ok
wechsel
was ist jetzt ok jetzt immer einmal die
kurzwaffe dazu die kurzwahl für das ist
gut
allerdings auch zu schlagen ja ok schön
stechen oder kleine hexe schlagen zu
große weil sonst der bundeswehr damit
man keine patronen verbraucht nachricht
ich nicht was unter umständen ja ja ja
ja keinen hass
was für die bundeswehr normal wären
nicht funktionieren
möglich
ist
dass sich nämlich aufwand der woche das
hast du nicht gedacht was
ich glaube ich bin eine wirkliche
bereicherung für die deutsche bundeswehr
wenn ich da jetzt mitmachen sagt ja
es gibt schlimmeres kamera
aber nicht viele nicht ja trotzdem aber
das war nicht weg durch engagement und
und kampfbereitschaft und dieser
gnadenlose welle einfach was für
deutschland zu tun also ich glaube es
gibt doch noch jobs wurde zum beispiel
socken zusammenstecken kannst so lassen
sich in puts werden oder waffen müssen
auch mal geputzt werden
ich merke schon ein bisschen mehr
aufsteigt ok jetzt alle noch mal extra
runde und zu haben darum
geht große rechts
[Musik]
und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe fans der feinsten unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere videos
sehen wollt
das war super trägt wir haben es euch
sie auch echt schlicke aus heute